[Musica]
ciao persona di colore con dei problemi
ai capelli è proprio saluta ciao
ma qui qui qui qui ho deciso mai non si
fa si fa e basta il doppio occhio c'è
uno dietro c'è uno che sta atterrando
sul parapetto notifier aspetta aspetta
aspetta ora che non riesco a centrare il
faccio perché sono tutto storto una
morte invece non ce l'ho fatta
occhio che che atterrano l'altro si può
di fronte a terra gente sparano sparano
io ho una padella abbiamo vinto e una
padella per uscire di qua in tutta
sicurezza a posto dove andiamo ciano vai
da dove la dott.sa dove aspetta per
ottenere alleniamoci dahlia di ucciderli
oddio no sette sono stati basati stronzo
è la mia con culo poi a mano io non ci
credo sono morto ma in questi venti capi
20 capi di casa ma no l'ho preso l'ho
uccisa il vero ci posso credere davvero
oggi si prega ama della meno possibile
sono forte bastardi aion ci venite a
prendermi altro che il martello di thor
fatto il culo a tutti ma later
noi giochiamo questo gioco dipende senza
registrare non per i fatti nostri
non è mai successo mais e forse l'azione
più bella che abbia mai il tifo della
mai tra i kill di padella di continuo
proprio che la free con le armi tra
l'altro jolo colpo della che la padella
dai folli si spera che commuovono e
uccidere e decido io non riesco ancora
credo di coca cola barcala capiani gente
felicemente rai geometrici aiuto no no
no no no no quando anche quella preso le
armi aiuto quando unica sei morto
ho trovato ne sei capace però non ha il
mirino ci sono buttato giù da un tetto
c'è stato oddio ma porca vacca che cagà
anzitutto no quanta gente c'è
niente mi che non ok ok ho un po non ci
sono più equa ok vuole morto eni con i
no non ci sono altri 8 sono entrata però
non ci sia c'è tanta gente che allevava
dell'udc ea beh se preferisci prendere
l'ultimo rilievo che la caviglia dopo ha
dentro che da dove hanno sparato aiuto
che col suo no no no no no no no no no
d'andata dove dove è quasi del di bo
destra se non lo so giovedì ma in fondo
nato per amica se mi tocca sono morte e
siamo in due
vado di sopra allora spetta però provare
tronano medikit come questo per curarmi
c'è un problema
non voglio sapere cioè se io esco il
tizio mi spara quindi non riuscire ma se
resto il costo è chiuso stai lì che ci
vediamo un altro gioco esci giochiamo a
happy chris ho colpito lo ha colpito ma
non è morto però gli ho fatto un po male
quella perdita la porta quasi a questi
va dall informazione capito è in avanti
è salito da sotto non era un altro
quello cioè su due per l'armatura primi
celam a cura di piero cosa sto vedendo è
sparato in faccia uno a un anno c'è
rimasta la freccia conficcata nel oggi
avremmo che lo zar vere salve io
rimorchio così le presentata lei sta
molto meglio adesso il denaro opere che
sto rimaniamo noi siamo artisti del make
up cliomakeup ci fa un baffo
siamo bravissimi ad alicante è diventata
[ __ ] questa doppia più o meno tre
ok col cazzo salve ma mi sa che non è
certo dice da il fratellone dipendi non
c'è più no non ci sta seguendo
cos'è un car chiaia dove sta a te sono
lontanissimi ecco stanno bruciando
davanti quadrati no
sì quando vendere 21 aspetta che vedo se
muoiono non è morto direi che se molti
poiché saranno noi ora ascolta mentre i
bambini qua
di qui il panico di di milano a base di
noi ora guarda mentre andremo là chi
siamo
ps puoi parlarmi anche se non siamo
vicini e laggiù comunque non ci sta
sparando noi ora siamo un chilometro poi
quale noi ora ma perché mia figlia
allora noi ora andiamo là e prendiamo
quel buggy per la salvezza
chi se li c'e gente che ci sta per
mirare in faccia al su sopra i container
quindi se cosa facciamo di breme hicks e
si corre non cruz leon mazzi perde
vedere questa cosa voglio vederla io
questa spendeva ammazzo distrae lo
distrae lo che lo ammazzo di sdraio più
di così non l'ho uccisa oggi che vola
nome kurdo mi le cure ce lo ha fatto
tieni di medici da fatto un volo di un
chilo a bersani ma è andata miccoli
serve quelli che appena di origine preso
questi si pregustavano il piano e
visioni che ha fatto un buon a bra che
si è concentrato sull'impegno che ha
lasciato corre qui da turbina
oggi su dove sto andando allora allora
allora
presentate
senti che se ci sono abbiamo dei
problemi devi capire che non puoi fare
ste stronzate certo doveste la patente
si cerca di avere una dignità dietro
dietro a pietro pietro pietro da talada
gesù ruolo del protesto bisogna sembra
che non subito magari torna in attacco
senza video occhio per occhio
pietro pietro no no no no pietro nota
marca di una bella moto la moto la
prendo io noto io no guido io ti devi
togliere ora dai vediamo vediamo
ma stai zitta li ho visti
valentino rossi guido di voi per me la
cosa prendo questa manovra il quadro di
andata bene mi e quante di morire
atrocemente ma fare quando ci con decine
invece questa parte di terna 10
no
come come siamo vivi come siamo vivi
come facciamo ad esseri vivi tra l'altro
stavi cadendo sul t tu hai visto che
stava succedendo una roba che ho detto
no va bene se succedere se uno era sul
tetto che cazzo vedeva esatto che doveva
fatto uscire dalla montagna mi trovo qui
ci mettiamo
non a caso nome non è quasi per la
goccia boy e novità sta interessando
vado è ok
cazzo noi no non ho fatto in tempo a
ricaricare o tre ragazzi dire che
possiamo concludere quadro un bel no
batte jones è stata una bellissima
esperienza classe i ragazzi servizio è
piaciuto è un argomento mi piace anche
ai soci giustizia ci si siede ci vediamo
subito dai ragazzi
[Musica]